welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny meeting
i'm councillor keith wallam and i'm
chairing the meeting today
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
do not interrupt other speakers if you
are attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed
by the council to have consented to
being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting
to being recorded by the council and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
yes yeah good morning before um we start
with the roll call of council's uh
present i'll just
introduce the officers present here
today and we have in the meeting
tom barker assistant director for
sustainable planning
philip isbell chief planning officer
simon
bailey team leader for heritage and
planning compliance
julie harvard business practice manager
and john maudsley
professional lead digital solutions
i will now do the roll call for
members present uh first of all
uh apologies chair sorry i'm skipping
ahead on the agenda for you
uh apologies for received from members
today are from council dawson
and councillor grandin and councillor
mayberry is substituting for councillor
brandon
thank you yes i am mr chairman if you
need confirmation
thank you
can i do the roll call yes please do
um counselor jane gould
yes good morning councilman avery
yes good morning councilman crawl
good morning council mclaren good
morning
councillor osborne good morning
councillor carter good morning
councillor castin good morning council
epc
good morning council muller good morning
council scarf good morning and council
willem
good morning
thank you we've done the apologies so we
are now on to
item two to receive any declarations of
pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest are there any
to declare please
no can we then turn to item 3
which is uh item jos
21 confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting
of the joint overview and scrutiny
committee held on the 23rd of november
2020 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
counsel wrapping you up good morning
chair uh yes
if we could turn to page nine
of the minutes bear with me while i get
there
item 7.11 yes
the last part of the sentence says as
the council
was under pressure to provide more
for residents i think that should be
more homes for residents
thank you and in item 7.15
i think where it says and domestic
developments were developed
in the future i think were sustainable
in the future
thank you and uh finally on
page 11 item 7.30
yes i believe that
it should be representative rather than
representation
in the second to last line
she wished
chair i wonder if i could intervene at
this point
um i note that you and i went through
the minutes
and made some suggested changes prior to
this being brought in
the minutes shown in the published
papers appear to be
an earlier draft prior to those
amendments so for example 7.9
still contains references as to 7.10 to
the suffolk drainage
flood risk subcommittee and that as i
pointed out in um the amendments made
that
in fact it's the um uh suffolk uh
flood management scrutiny subcommittee
so
if that one's missing i suspect all of
these are missing
i'd like to propose that these minutes
be brought back at a subsequent meeting
um of the joint committee obviously that
can't be done now until february
but i have a suspicion that these
minutes
have have reverted to an earlier version
uh basically remember we we um yeah we
went through these i i don't know if you
can
confirm that henry yet but it looks that
way to me
yes yeah i think you're right and i do
apologize i am not sure how that's
happened
because it was such a lengthy um of of
minutes
and there were so many technical details
that it was necessary for us to do a
line-by-line
analysis and correction and i don't
think these minutes are fit to be voted
upon as they stand
so councillor mccrory would you like to
propose that they be deferred to a
future
yes i'd like to propose they'd be
deferred till the next available meeting
of the joint
uh overview and scrutiny committee
rather than the january ones which will
be the separate councils
thank you and we have a second i believe
councillor ek ping young
yes chair i'm happy to second councillor
mccror's proposal
um although i would hope that um in the
intervening period we might be
mailed um a copy of the correct minutes
in
in the meantime yes i think that would
be entirely keeping as i say we did do a
line by line correction because
we were dealing with so many bodies and
getting all the names
exactly right and plus some of the other
references there were some grammatical
things so
i'd be happy with that if if if the
chair of this meeting would be happy
with that
indeed yes i think that that is the
that's the best way forward
do we need to converge on the deferment
then
henriette uh yes we would need to vote
on the deferment uh just one moment jam
i'll just uh have a look at the voting
because we would need to change the
wording in the vote
yes thank you one moment please
henry i've just added another vote for
you
thank you mandy right so we would need
to vote on
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 23rd november 2020 be deferred to
the next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
so we will start the vote just bear with
me
it's been started so members please can
you vote now on that
item
and yet i'm still unable to get in
electronically so
i vote for you got four
that's fine thank you very much council
gould
right so the
so the vote has
been completed and we have nine votes
four
and one abstention so we have ten votes
for sorry chair
and one abstention thank you very much
can we move then on to the next item
which is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's
petition scheme non-received chair
and questions by the public non-received
and questions by counsellors
non-received chair
thank you very much
so we then move on to item
um it's item
it is item seven item seven which is
a planning enforcement the
transformation update
and i'd like to invite philip isabel to
introduce
his report please thank you chairman
good morning members
so this is an update report slightly
later than expected
uh an unusual year has caused some
unusual effects
as you may recall we reported to
overview and scrutiny
in february and were
tasked to come back with within six
months with an update report
and at that time also to set up a
working group
to review the joint local planning
enforcement
policy um i've got colleagues this
morning as you've
heard john maudsley julia havard and
simon bailey who will talk to some of
the detail of this
in turn as we go within the report i
thought i'd just do a little
introduction
uh to kind of set some overall context
uh it's been a challenging time since
february uh obviously
and uh with coveted pandemic there was a
large portion of the year where we've
suspended
uh work on sites in relation to
enforcement and suspended some
notice serving and certainly in relation
to the work of the courts and
prosecutions that has also been put into
suspension by
uh by reason of uh the coveted pandemic
uh we are now picking up the threads of
uh those things and have been doing so
for for some months now through the
summer
but obviously that did in its own right
creates somewhat of a backlog of work of
sites needing uh
inspections uh and i think our
experience has been that there was
a volume of work came in associated with
people being more present at home
and there were able to observe things in
their own uh neighborhoods
uh more frequently than otherwise been
the case
and experience across other parts of uh
the county and in essex does suggest
generally and this is anecdotal that
there has been an uplift in
uh enforcement investigations being
reported
to councils uh uh through the
the period since march so uh in the
middle of the year
uh and well shortly before we began the
uh the
the lockdown period uh work had started
uh to
uh take the transformation activity
forward
and since that time we've progressed
that
that's gained more traction as we've
come through the summer and into the
autumn
and indeed we've taken a focus upon
the volume of cases that were most aged
and there are various appendices and
colleagues will talk to some of the
detail behind that
but in essence we have been working to
reduce
the backlog of older cases that were
present in the system
and we have concurrently been looking to
both
map out uh uh the uh the the the state
of a generic enforcement process
uh this is uh th this is in one of the
appendices and i won't talk to it now
because
uh mr mortally will talk to a little to
that in a bit more detail
but in essence that's a useful piece of
activity which from my point of view
would also serve to assist the
consideration of
any members working on a review of the
joint local planning enforcement policy
and with that in mind what you have
before you was an update report
i think it's fair to say my my sense of
this is that uh
there is much more work to be done and i
think reporting back to this committee
in uh six months time would be a useful
thing to do
and i'm conscious that on a personal
level the expectation was that there
would be a joint member officer
a task and finished group established
back in february of
this year that didn't take place and uh
circumstances prevailed against that but
since that time there has been some
effective work done
uh by a group of members forming the
joint local plan member working group
from across both councils
and i think that group is quite familiar
with planning issues and is possibly
very well placed to
uh assist with a review of the joint
local planning enforcement policy
and to have regard to best practice
elsewhere and to look at other policies
as we look at ours so i won't
go into too much further detail it's
fair to say it's been a challenging year
various steps have been taken through
that year and i think it's possibly
most useful to start with a review of
where we are with the active
investigations
and our progress with those and if i
could hand over to simon bailey that's
what i'd like to do now chairman
thank you simon uh thank you chair thank
you phil
um so at the start of the year we had
uh 380 cases i think if i direct you to
appendix a we've got a pie chart which
indicates where we were at the first of
jan 2020
you'll see from that around two-thirds
of our cases
um were over 26 weeks old
uh we've given some uh focus
to those um committing some time and
resource to them to put them back on the
agenda
um and uh that has resulted in
a significant reduction in those numbers
if you scroll down to the
uh the second pie chart within that
appendix um
you'll see that they the over 26 weeks a
number of cases has come down to 152
so if my math is right that's about a 37
reduction in old cases in that period
part of that was also uh the process
mapping which
um my colleague john moores lee will
talk to in a little while
um around the as as phil's already
alluded to the process of mapping a
typical enforcement case
we've updated that a few times during
that
that process of mapping it out and then
use that to inform how we
use the enterprise software to task
the offices with um
how they operate a typical case
we've used some other tools as well to
help us try and achieve that
reduction in case numbers i mean overall
case numbers
have come down we've we've been working
on bringing numbers down
uh since the sort of inception of the of
the process of uh um
reviewing where we were and mapping how
we go about doing enforcement cases so
to give you a few numbers we started off
with about 420 cases at the beginning of
november
2019. uh we were down to
340 at the beginning of february and and
as low as 260 at the beginning of march
obviously the covid situation has um
quelled our reduction in cases somewhat
by by virtue of the fact that
as phil's alluded to we weren't able to
get out and do site visits for
a lot of our cases um particularly the
new ones coming through
so they effectively got put on hold
during
lockdown one and then we had a bit of a
backlog of things to do
when we came out of lockdown um and with
um
you know progressing uh site visits
again uh
in a covered secure risk assessed manner
so
uh we've been working back from that
that position we're currently around
um 380 cases again so
you know we started off in one position
at the beginning of the year
we um made some significant progress up
until
uh lockdown and then it's kind of taken
a bit of a backward step
and we've been um uh bringing ourselves
back to
to essentially where we started at the
beginning of this year
using the the processes and tools that
we've put in place as part of this
transformation work
um another one of the tools that we've
used is
um preparation of 14 day lists
a report that um uh my colleague john
mosley has prepared for us
um and provided to the team on on a
daily basis
uh that's accompanied by two weekly
meetings one for our
east area and one for our west area uh
the report covers a 28-day period
looking
forward to actions set up in the in the
um
case management software uniform which
are coming due in the next
14 days and looking back for 14 days for
any actions in uniform which is still
outstanding
uh the purpose of that being to embed
within the team the the behaviors needed
for progressing steps
um of an enforcement investigation in a
timely manner
um and ensuring the next action is set
out with a due date to remind them
and then actions when if not before it
comes due
so essentially to use the 14 day report
as a as a shopping list of things to do
we've also used i think this is
referred to in the report before you
used blitz days
uh three of uh to give focus to all our
cases but particularly those over 26
weeks old
and the process involves pooling our
resources
by enlisting the help of uh colleagues
in the in the dm team
um to provide a fresh pair of eyes to
give an opinion to
suggest next steps uh with the aim of
then uh giving impetus to move cases on
and it's a it's a collaborative approach
um it's not this
you know it's it's not dm officers
telling enforcement officers what to do
it's
simply a mechanism for drawing attention
uh to those matters where it's needed
and weeding out those where it might not
be considered
appropriate or expedient or in the
public interest to pursue
um that might be a good point to
uh lead over to um my colleague john
moores need to talk about the
process mapping um
did i just ask a question um you
you and phil have both talked about the
increase in numbers
of cases and phil said it's probably
because to a degree it's probably
because
there were people walking about seeing
things they hadn't seen before
but was not the increase in cases
also to do with businesses having to
find new ways of working for instance
um eating establishments um
and also extending working hours
deliveries to
supermarkets and so on am i right that
that made
that gave an increase in the number of
cases as well
you're all right cheb uh but a
relatively minor increase
in in number of cases we have around 30
um cases that we've put onto a a
separate code
for temporary tolerance during that
during the covid
situation um there was
we had some uh guidance from government
uh via
written ministerial statements the first
one being around
um retail delivery time so if they want
to do out of hours delivery times
um they could do so uh without without
us coming at them
for for a breach of condition um there
was maybe
i think we had four of those we had
the next uh advice from government was
around construction working hours
um we've had a set of um of cases set up
in relation to those
but these these cases were set up um
so that we could uh provide a period of
tolerance to
to assist with the economic and to some
degree social recovery from the
covid crisis um and it's set up in
as an enforcement case because the the
software that we operate for case
management
has the functionality to set up actions
with a future date
with a due date so we can be alerted to
monitor if the breach continues or if
it's been removed
which which is not a functionality that
i believe is available within the within
the development management
side of the software so um you know a
lot of those cases have not
risen out of complaints they've arisen
because businesses have come to us and
said this is what we want to do
and we've confirmed that that's
acceptable and we've we've advised them
that we're going to set up a case to
to monitor it and we'll come back to
them at a later date
um we have seen as
as phil's alluded to we have seen an
uptick in um
complaint cases from members of the
public um councillors
uh other other uh departments within the
organization
um relating to you know our perception
being that that is related to people
being
stuck at home and not able to get out
and they're seeing what their neighbors
are doing and
coming to us asking to confirm mostly
asking to confirm that that's acceptable
um we've had a few things that have come
to us around uh whether or not it's
appropriate for um
builders to be operating on site and not
observe social distancing measures
which obviously is not something that
we're able to tackle directly so we
might need to refer that to another
department or over to the police or
somebody else who might be better
able to approach that particular issue
so
a variety of stuff has come our way and
not necessarily all
things that we could deal with thank you
phil you you've got your hand up did you
want to add to that
i i think simon's covered it thank you
chairman i mean the broad point is that
albeit that the government has
encouraged us to take a tolerant
approach it's fair to say that uh not
everybody in the community has quite
seen that that tolerance is appropriate
so
the torrents cases in inverted commerce
have been set up
simply so that we have a record and you
know we are
managing the situation that they
represent but it's it's certainly true
to say that uh
this hasn't necessarily meant that um
all communities are
uh equally tolerant about some of these
items thank you jim
thank you um uh councillor pingyoung
you've got a query and then we then
we'll move on to
to to hear from john
thank you chair uh the uh i think
to some extent um philip has covered
this one but
it seems to me looking at the chart on
page
53 which is the cases reported month by
month over the last
three years there has been a significant
increase in
2000 in this year compared to three
years ago
by a magnitude of at least two so i just
be keen to understand where that
increase is coming from
really and and to what extent it's
impacting the work that
the team are doing and how they're going
to to uh
challenge that take care of that in and
and mitigate it
thank you shall we shall we press on
and hear from john and julie because
perhaps that will be covered in their
presentations
if not we'll come back to to to phil or
simon
uh at the end of the uh presentations if
that's okay thank you chair i can answer
that one later if that's
okay that's absolutely fine thank you
uh thank you chair yes as you can see um
in
appendix e uh the enforcement floor
chart is included
um as you can see that's version 2.4 so
we have been through several iterations
of this
um up to up to up to date where we are
now
um so this was essential really to
map out this process so we could
identify the steps
necessary at each stage from receipt
through to conclusion
that we could then bolt onto our
enterprise software which would then
enable us to track
where the offices are with each case and
the time scales for each case and each
of those actions
so if you would like to look at info
enforcement flow chart
and appendix e
you can see that the administration side
from receipt through to advising the
officer should take
three working days now this is something
that we can
add into our enterprise software that
will then
highlight where those cases are going
beyond three days or not or whether they
are reaching
uh the three days to the case officer we
can then
produce performance charts for each
officer in terms of how far they're
reaching those targets
so within three working days the
complaint comes in
the complaint is then triaged to
determine whether it's a planning matter
or it's not a planning matter if it's
not
then we can say that there's no further
action we can update the complainant and
reporter
and signpost them to another department
or authority if needed
um john i'm sorry to interrupt i do
apologize chair
i did raise my hand uh is it possible to
display any sections of that on screen
of course yeah i will just share that
would be really helpful for not only for
members but for any members of the
public
who that might be watching this or
watching it later
okay so it should be coming up now
thank you is is that okay is that can
you see everything on the screen because
it's
it's fairly small
so as you can see the complaint comes in
um
it's then triaged to determine whether
it's a planning matter
no further action we then update the
complaint in a reporter
it can either go to an enquiry which
will then be screened
a case is set up in our uniform system
which is then allocated to admin
the admin then consult the case officer
case is created and then it's
allocated to an enforcement officer if
it is a planning matter
we can check the uniform for the case
history we can either add to the
existing case
and then advise the officer or we can
set up a brand new case in the system
which then goes through several steps
such as adding a location plan
advise the plotting team to plot this um
specially in the system
we can send the acknowledgement letter
to the reporter via email
allocate the case officer and then
upload all the relevant documents to our
document management system
and all of this occurs within three
working days of receipt
so prior to having this flow chart we
didn't have any time scales in terms of
of all of these steps so this has been
essential really to
to inform that and also to set up the
enterprise system
we then move on to the second stage
so the officer has been advised
to then do a desktop assessment
and then conduct a site visit now in
terms of the priorities of the site
visit
if it's high that should be going out
within three working days of receipts so
as soon as they're told
uh by the admin team there's high
priority case they should be
performing that um site visit
as soon as medium and low or within 10
working days of receipt
as you can see there are different steps
so the stage 1 x
expediency recommendation time scales
are at the bottom there
within one working day of site visit
within two working days of site visits
so these yellow lines are time scales
that we can then map into our
enterprise software which will then show
up on the office's caseload
and we can then performance manage
through crystal reports or
other systems that we have
running through again planning
enforcement history to be completed with
three
working days of the site visit if
the um officer needs to consult internal
departments
external uh departments or colleagues
then one working day of the breach being
confirmed
response is then expected within three
working days for high and ten working
days for medium on law
the administration team can then monitor
that through the system
moving on to the last slide
so the expediency report for high
priority cases
is expected within 10 working days of
breach suspected
or medium and low within 20 working days
of the breach being suspected
as you can see if it's acceptable we can
then invite an application
application received through to
determination
if it's unacceptable we can issue a
cease and desist letter
planning contravention notice our
enforcement other notice
the thing that goes to repeal lodge and
then that will sit with pins
this last section is yet to be uh added
to our enterprise system
what we have done is is focused on the
initial and the middle stages first
to get those targets in the system so we
can then report
either via the daily um rolling
reports which is which is highlighted
here or through case management in one
to ones
this the daily rolling report that simon
mentioned
it's been very useful in terms of
looking 14 days ahead
also 14 days back and it's drilled down
to
specific actions within each case so not
only are we getting an update
for the cases we're getting an update on
the specific actions on what they are
doing next
what the case officer is doing next and
the time scales
if those time scales are not met then
they'll fall into the second half of
this report
or we can then chase that up with the
officer so it's really drilling down to
specific actions which has been the
improvement i think
and that is is that okay enough for now
yes thank you very much
shall we shall we move straight on is
julie going to
um give us a presentation as well
not totally a presentation but i can
explain what we've been doing
on with regards to the
administration side of enforcement and
how we're working with
the existing dm customer service team
to improve the support to to a very
small team in respect of admin um
we are report uh new reports are being
set up within the three working days
uh previously this was taking a lot
longer
10 10 days plus because we were doing a
lot of work up front so we were
we were researching the histories we
were checking the constraints on the
site
and they may or may not have been
relevant to the case
so what we've decided to do is to get
the case set up initially
with a view to doing additional work in
relation to
checking histories and constraints
further down the line
so there is an opportunity for officers
to ask for the full
history later in the process
the enforcer the enterprise task has
been created to confirm that a customer
has been sent an acknowledgement
so as soon as admin complete that
initial stage of the process the the
task
is removed from their list so we've got
a double check that we are actually
keeping customers informed
we are providing cover by
the dm customer service team at the
moment we only have
two admin staff one uh full-time and one
part-time within the enforcement team
we've got one person a part-time
person on maternity leave at the moment
which hasn't been replaced
and we are working to try and provide
cover within the general dm team
to support the enforcement admin
two of the team in dm have been trained
to cover the phones and to set up new
reports
which has also assisted us meeting the
targets of three days to get
new reports set up on the system
we've also agreed with our information
unit
in it that we will turn around
new cases the plotting of new cases
within 24 hours
this is what we were already
achieving through the validation of new
applications in dm
but the enforcement plotting was
probably uh
given uh sort of a second second um
line behind dm but now both both types
of applications are being plotted within
24 hours
we're having regular admin team meetings
so building a wider knowledge within the
dm
team of enforcement cases and and
the vice versa so we're actually
we've also achieved um increasing
knowledge in our
first point of contact when customer
queries come into the dm team
because they don't always go straight to
enforcement
so we're building uh support officer
confidence to assist with officers
to carry out other tasks such as land
registry searches
consulting internal departments such as
environmental health heritage and legal
and drafting up correspondence what we
want to do is to
build the knowledge of the support team
within enforcement
to enable the officers to actually do
the physical site visits and to be able
to write up the reports
we're also reviewing the suite of
templates that are available
so um benefiting officers
because a lot of the data is standard so
the
templates can be used in most cases
which means they can save time
and ensure we ensure consistency across
the team
but this still allows bespoke
information to be added to individual
notices
validation team previously were very
wary about
sending enforcement case applications
back
so when
a customer was advised that an
application was required
quite often we just received an
application form
and not very detailed supporting
information
the validation team are now working with
applicants
explaining exactly what's required and
if all circumstances fail we will
send an application back and pass it
back to our enforcement team
to action further i think previously
they were just
being left on hold um they weren't being
processed because there was a fear that
because it was an enforcement case
um we should be giving people longer to
to reply to questions but actually what
we found is
that they they didn't so cases were just
sitting there so now we're working with
the enforcement team as
as regards the validation process as
well trying to get applications valid
um that's all i have
to say about that so i'll hand back to
phil
to uh talk about the joint local
planning enforcement policy
thank you really um yes i think it's
fair to say uh chairman that
you you're looking at a work in progress
um the
uh workflow mapping is you know still to
be
uh fully uh tasked into enterprise and
colleagues who are helping with that are
you know developing and learning the
software as we go
and in terms of the active use of this
um
the reports and the information
available to officers to help them
self-manage their cases is
where this goes uh the reality of this
is that this is a learning point to
encourage uh that kind of
self-discipline of managing cases which
we will be continuing to do as we go
into the spring
in practical terms these reports and and
this information
has really only been uh in circulating
within the team in a in
a workable way since october uh
and uh it is going to take time for it
to become
uh second nature um and readily usable
so that you know throughout the process
of an enforcement investigation
uh we're clear that the the cases are
moving
uh smoothly and not uh not bumping into
the sides as
may historically have been the case the
process mapping of itself is is is you
know uh
useful to uh the uh question of um
mapping out how enforcement uh could and
should work there will always be
uh a need to tailor its particular
circumstances to the particular
investigation in hand
but i think it's also highly relevant to
a review of the joint local planning
enforcement policy and this probably
then becomes the starter of a
conversation
uh within a a working group to actually
look at
how that workflow is and what it could
and should be
in order to set a policy that ensures
that
both communities members of the public
and those investigated as well as
councillors know precisely
how we are going to conduct
investigations so that
uh we we have a uh a a transparent
approach
um but one which uh doesn't pull any
punches and is quite clear about the way
in which we will approach an
investigation
albeit that you can never truly uh i i
think
uh say more than something that's
generic because the
expediency issues particularly to any
given investigation will differ case by
case
so uh you know to conclude the
recommendation to committee today is to
uh instruct the setting up of a tax
task and finish group uh and i would
suggest that the
uh group that's been reviewing the joint
local planning uh policy
joint local plan uh for the councils has
been effective
and is working well together and you
know is well uh well versed in planning
issues to be able to
thrash around some of the ideas that
associate with enforcement and the
investigation
of uh complaints so um chairman
unconscious counselor epignong did uh
ask a question
um as regards the uptick in complaints
and i think simon did indicate he'd
um provide a start to that answer and
with your agreement uh i'd suggest simon
comes back in at this point
i'm happy to take any other questions
uh thanks phil thank you chair uh just
to um answer
uh councillor acting young's question
from earlier uh in the period first of
april
to uh 10th of december 2019 we had 403
cases coming
to the team in the same period uh this
year first of april 2020 to
10th of december we had 588 which is a
45
increase in in case cases received
year on year thank you and
do we know what uh is spurring that huge
increase
i mean it seems to definitely be
increasing year by year
uh we don't directly know i think i
think our perception is that there's
because we've had lockdown in that
period as well there's been you know
more time spent at home has meant that
people
are looking out the windows more and and
seeing what their neighbours are doing
and are concerned by what might be
happening
um as i um uh mentioned earlier i think
some of that is
uh we've received inquiries from members
of the public concerns that
um building works continuing and there's
not the social distancing that should be
happening and you know where we've
received complaints like that we've
we've advised customers of
the provisions provided by government to
extend working hours
and also that the maintaining social
distancing
requirement is not something that we can
act on on their behalf so we've
you know in that respect we've directed
them to to
other teams within the organization or
else externally elsewhere to the to the
police
okay simon i i so i i guess
your anticipation would be that in 2021
the number of cases would coming in
would start to go down
i'm just concerned about that the
workload on on on your team really
if this case load continues to increase
yeah i mean i i i don't think i'm not
expecting a continued increase in the
number of cases coming in
um in the in the in the same period for
2018 we got two and
uh 275 cases so uh i would
i would hope that um 2021 2022 would see
a reduction back to that sort of level
um i think we'll still have a number of
cases on our books
um under the uh tolerance uh code that
we that we've
um put in place to assist with
uh things like extended delivery hours
and um you know
sort of external uh developments at um
pudge for example
to accommodate uh social distancing
requirements so
you know whilst those things might be um
tolerable under the uh under the uh
sort of economic recovery from covid um
circumstances they might not necessarily
be tolerable tolerable under ordinary
circumstances so you know we'll need to
get those
um cases monitored and reviewed so there
is a job of work within there
i i don't i don't um anticipate that
they're just going to disappear i think
you know
there's going to be some chasing uh to
be done with those in order to either
get those things
um granted planning permission or
removed as
appropriate um i'm not expecting
um the increase in in new cases to
to be uh persistent i think it will drop
back down again to
the levels that we've previously seen
thank you very much thank you now i will
go around the whole of
the joint committee um so that everyone
gets a chance to
to uh ask questions this is just for
questions
and then we'll do the same a bit later
on for the debate everybody will get a
chance to
to speak so can i move on now please to
councillor mclaren
thank you chair um yes and this question
is for simon actually
i meant to ask it in the members
briefing and i didn't
um when cases are being allocated
to officers is that on a geographic
basis
or on a selective basis
thank you thank you council mclaren uh
yes it is
um we have uh two teams um within within
the enforcement teams
so officers are split east and west uh
so we have um
three officers uh for each of those
teams currently
um the west area has one officer uh off
on maternity leave
um so apparently there's only two
officers in that in that
dealing with cases in that space but yes
they are
they are divided up or allocated to
officers on a geographic basis
um there isn't necessarily a split
within the areas as to who gets it other
than the type of case coming in so
those cases involving uh listed
buildings or unauthorized works to
protected trees would go to a higher
grade officer than
for example complaints about sheds and
fences or you know a minor
breach of condition because there seems
to be looking at the
uh detail there seems to be sort of
areas where
there seems to be more complaints uh
than others yeah and i think centers of
population
will elicit more complaints than than um
you know the depths of the countryside
so slow market sudbury
um needham to some extent you know uh
those areas are going to attract
um or or result in more complaints
because there's
people closer together uh whereas that
in the countryside there might be
things that um people do that they their
neighbors
because they're a distance away might
not necessarily see or decide to
lodge a report about thank you very much
thank you
thank you um councillor scarf
please
thank you chair yeah i mean i was going
to sort of
ask the question i mean based on the
fact that we sort of understand why the
reasons that cases have gone up and with
the
covert situation how we can't deal with
them quite in the same way that we
we used to um are you confident
over the next year or so that you can
reduce those cases
number again because you obviously made
great strides
um from november 19 to early 2020 to
reduce the number of cases
and then along came covered which
obviously has resulted in a lot more
cases for you
including the kovid tolerance cases but
are you confident with the resources
that you have to hand and
um the mapping process and the new
technology that you can reduce those
over perhaps the next 12 months or do
you
is there a resource issue there or
anything like that that you would
wish us to be aware of simon
thank you council scarf and i i don't
think there's a resource issue um
our member of uh our officer within the
team that's due to
uh that is currently off on tennessee is
due to return to the team
um towards the end of march um that will
help us
um with the case numbers that we cove we
have already
uh the the the workflow process mapping
um will assist with uh directing
officers in terms of how they need to
progress their cases
um we haven't had a a process like that
before so
because we weren't um tasking officers
in the same way
uh and they were um in in effect
managing their own case
load as they saw um best
um you know to some extent those that
shouted loudest got the most action
so if there was a particular
particularly persistent complainant
about a particular matter then they
would get
resourced because they are asking the
most or
or or going through other channels so
you know they might lodge a formal
complaint about the
the fact that their case had not been
dealt with um quickly enough and it
might be about a fence or a parking
space or something similar like that
so um what we're now trying to do
through the through the workflow mapping
is make sure that each and every case is
is um actions um in a
reasonable time period so that all cases
are moved forward
um concurrently as best we can
in order to try and make sure that
everything gets dealt with
and doesn't and nothing is left to sit
um and i think with that process in
place that should enable us to make sure
that we
move those investigations forward to a
resolution or conclusion of some
description
um the other step that might be um
relevant to
your question is the desktop assessment
that's within the workflow that um
uh my colleague john maunstein referred
to earlier
and i think that is an important step
for officers to look at cases
and and and see what the complaint is
what what's being reported
and whether or not it's something that
we need to even do a site visit for
because it might be something that
you know if a complainant is is does not
understand planning rules in the in the
detail that we do
the fact that they might have complained
about their neighbors shed going up
right next to their fence
might not actually result in a planning
breach it might be something that falls
within permitted development rules
we can advise them of that um and uh
hopefully that case can then be be
closed off with without us even having
to go out to site so
there are there are um parts within that
workflow process that
should help us to reduce case numbers
swiftly
thank you phil did you want to add to
that
yes if i if i can do chairman that would
be appreciated
um certainly i think from our point of
view the question of resources it
remains under review at the moment i
think it's
probably still too early to draw a
conclusion about it because i think
we're still
getting things into a new process but
both simon myself tom
are alive to the question of what's the
appropriate resource to do this
uh as an activity um and it's also true
that with the joint working with
uh planning officers doing blitz day and
other things that we've had
uh you know considerable progress in uh
actually team working and uh you know
helping to actually get to the bottom of
some of the the naughty planning
problems that exist within some of these
investigations
and the reality is that that's both a
learning exercise for planning officers
and the learning exercises uh for
enforcement officers at the same time as
taking
investigations forward so you know that
that shared activity and that shared
purpose
focusing on particular cases to you know
get get
get to a conclusion um it doesn't
necessarily resolve the the planning
breach or the investigation
and as i think as as john said in
relation to to the video mapping
um you know we still have not mapped out
the appeal process or what happens once
we've served a notice so we've got more
work to do on that
uh and the reality is that baby members
will be you know well aware that we've
recently fought and succeeded in a an
enforcement case in burs at cuckoo hill
um you know the question of that has
involved quite considerable officer cost
and time
uh and and you know to get an
investigation of that
nature which is probably the the most
detailed sort of enforcement
investigation you do
at the moment we've probably spent over
fifty thousand pounds on
uh on on legal advice and other matters
associated with it it is not
you know uh enforcement uh when it
happens in that
grain detail does require you know a
solid level of resource and a solid
level of commitment
and experience so i think simon and i
are highly alive to getting the right
resource onto
the cases under investigation uh and at
the moment
i think i wouldn't conclude that
there is necessarily the wrong profile
of resource against
uh investigations um but there's more
work to do on that and i'm
reserving my judgment chairman thank you
very much phil
um councillor mccraw
thank you chair my apologies for that
slight delay there um
i'm just observing the cases reported um
that table on page 53 of the papers of
the agenda
and simon's alluded to it in some ways
and i think it's where council epione
started off looking at a rise in figures
from november
17 through to november 20 a three year
period
and there is an overall upward trend but
i mean i i wonder if it's
fair to say this and i'd like to ask
officers if that i'm correct in this
assumption
that reports made are not directly under
our the council's control
or officers control because those are
just possible
perhaps perception um we have an overall
i think great
perhaps i just is this perception
correct that there's greater awareness
of the very existence of planning
conditions and that the perception of a
breach
is not necessarily a breach in itself
which is more or less i think what
you've been
driving towards but i think that that is
that a fair
assessment that there is a greater
awareness and understanding
that planning conditions exist and maybe
people are uh
are more inclined to to say hang on a
minute what about that
which is which might not be a it's a
case reported
it doesn't necessarily mean it's a
complaint if you follow me
[Music]
so i'm going to say that thank you yeah
thank you
uh cancer mcgraw um i think i think
that's true to an extent um
there is probably a greater awareness of
of planning requirements
um among certain sectors of the of the
general population uh
it's possibly not um in terms of the
fine detail but if
um for example large housing
developments are proposed
um in or around villages then
then i think there's probably uh they
draw attention
from from the existing populace and they
you know will make representations and
and and be aware of uh the decision and
um possibly the conditions within that
decision
and where they're uh possibly slightly
aggrieved at the
decision being made to grant planning
permission they may then
you know look at making sure that that
development is
carried out absolutely enough 100
in accordance with the conditions
attached to that permission
um you know when we do get complaints
like that we need to review
um how much of a breach
has occurred if if one has occurred at
all
um and and uh go back to the developer
to make sure that they're either
uh doing things um properly or that
they're aware that they're
on the fringes and as a supplementary to
that if i may chair yes of course the
instance of multiple related reports
um of a breach which is maybe not
exactly the same breach
do we double count or do we just count
that as one report
um if it was broadly the same i think we
would probably add it to the same case
if it was relating to two different
conditions but on the same permission
that would be
two separate cases though they probably
would go to the same officer
because it would not make sense to have
two different officers dealing with the
same thing dealing with the same site
thank you thank you very much tom did
you want to come in at this point
um yes thank you chair i was just
looking to supplement the answer that
simon gave in terms
of that kind of greater visibility of
the planning process and i think the
growth in neighborhood planning
which a number of our communities we've
now got 50 communities across the
two districts looking at neighborhood
plans and i think
that is another mechanism through which
people's eyes are opened as to the
planning process
and might be leading to a kind of
greater sense of expectation
um and an increase in reporting so i
just thought i'd
just weigh that in because i think
certainly
that ground-up approach to planning and
neighborhood plans driving that we'll
certainly be giving
some parishes a much greater
understanding of
what the planning process is how things
work through and and therefore a kind of
closer
eye in terms of whether developments are
going ahead as proposed thank you
can i move on now to councillor carter
please
thank you and apologies in advance i'm
having a bit of a special time at
moments i do
hopefully not swear what must do that
all right um
looking at the um of the charter
i might be a mistake but the uh where
it's written the
regards be actual current cases
uh it's just via ones are currently
available so
um sorry about me two seconds
um maybe i'll come back to you whilst my
wife
leaves
okay we'll come back to councillor
carter councillor mayberry
thank you very much mr chairman um i
would
first of all like to say that i thought
the member briefing
on enforcement was extremely useful for
all members and i think it's given us a
greater insight into the
complex issues of an enforcement case
secondly i would like to also say that i
think simon
and tom are absolutely right in what
they are saying about the enforcement
um but i would like to add to simon
about
um large developments near
established buildings i actually think
that sometimes
if people are aggrieved that they will i
would suggest
just try to be a bit awkward which
causes more work for
enforcement and tom's
excuse me comment on more villages or
parishes having
neighborhood plans or looking into those
yes they have a greater insight into
what is happening but i think i have
actually two questions
if you could help me please first of all
could i have an example of an legal
issue
rather than heritage or something else
are we talking about legal as in the
planning
condition or are we talking about legal
as just something else that i don't
understand
that's my first question um and
my second question i have gotten to
write it down so i'll i'll think about
it
thank you tom you've got your hand up is
it to answer that question
sorry no the hand is sorry just a legacy
um i'll leave um simon to answer that
question
okay thank you simon thank you chair uh
thank you councillor maybe i
i i think the reference to legal cases
is probably
um in terms of us getting a court date
and i think the courts are
experiencing some backlog following um
lockdown and
also as a result of trying to put in
place um
covert secure measures so so that
obviously the two parties subject to a
legal action are able to be
in the same room at the same time or to
do it via some other mechanism and i i'm
not sure that it's
um i know one one case that's in my in
my mind that we need to
progress on i'm not sure that it would
be appropriate to try and request the
defendants to do that through zoom or or
teams or some other
online meeting arrangement because i
don't think they would have that
facility so
when it when it comes to uh legal issues
like that i think
we are struggling a little bit to get a
court date because the courts are
struggling to get
arrangements in place to get people into
courtrooms
thank you thank you mr chairman i've
remembered my second question and i do
apologize for that
um julie was talking about um
validation and i and i would just like
to expand
that a little more if possible so my
question
on that is um because you were having
difficulty with validating
and enforcement and can you just confirm
that that was because you were
requesting a planning application and
um i'm going to say the defendant
whoever the householder was or
whatever um they were resisting that
please i think i think the the reason
that
it was it was um it's difficult to
validate some of the enforcement cases
is that um is people's understanding
that an application form needs to be
completed and submitted
but we have to treat enforcement cases
like any other planning application
so they have to provide the details as
per the national and the local
validation requirements
as if the application wasn't already as
if the
the proposal wasn't already built and
they were looking to retain
whatever so i think we've we've
struggled
with providing probably the applicants
with the advice
at the initial stages so we're much more
detailed in saying what is required
the validation team are able to offer
that advice to the enforcement officer
so any point in time when the officer
goes back to the applicant
and says this is what's required you
need to make an application
we actually detail the documentation
that would be
necessary to submit that application and
for it to go through the process
so i think we've also had instances
at the moment the quality of some of the
applications actually coming into the dm
team are poor because people are
struggling
through covid to find people to be able
to actually help them
submit applications especially if they
don't want to go to
planning agents that you know they're
struggling to to
provide specialist reports uh with that
with applications
but we have we have a slight flexibility
but
we can't really be expected to reduce
the requirement to submit details for
enforcement cases
so we're we're explaining generally
you know what they need where they can
find it do they need to go to an agent
to actually help them submit the
application
but we we need that we need that
documentation to be able to do a full
uh publicity process so
for people involved neighbours involved
parish councils involved
so when they look at the plans and the
details submitted on that application
they can make an informative decision
on whether they can support or object to
the application
thank you very much that helps thank you
thank you can i go to councillor osborne
please
thank you mr chairman um yes it's um
mostly about clarification really and
and um uh and i don't want to be like uh
the playwright john osborne look back in
anger
but could could simon just um
tell me about the uh i when he first
was on the enforcement area at corks
lane
there were a lot of backlog of legal um
stuff that hadn't sort of come forward
did we get
did we get rid of all of that uh area of
of
backdated enforcement uh cases
or are they still hanging around and how
many of those uh like paul eppelong was
saying
um council paul abner was saying that um
uh obviously the the numbers that you've
given
do they relate to any back cases that go
back
a great many or two or three years
either before covert obviously
uh and and secondly um what i'd like to
know is
uh how many cases uh
that i say were dated uh before
uh 2017-18 uh
numbers have not been able to be
enforced
and thirdly i'd just like to say that um
it's good to hear the actions from julie
on the conditions and also from
uh uh john and philip for the uh
feedback and for yourself thank you
thank you
simon uh thank you councillor osborne
so yeah we have um taken uh steps on
reducing the number of um older cases um
uh as uh outlined um previously
um some of those we have reached a
conclusion on in terms of
um the the issue has been resolved with
us
without us having to resort to formal
enforcement action
some of them are already subject to
notices
and perhaps require um legal action so
um we've already um
uh progressed to service of an
enforcement notice we've already
prosecuted that notice the next step for
us is to seek an injunction to have the
um unauthorized development removed um
so you know there will be those cases a
bit like
as phil's already alluded to the the
cuckoo hill case in viewers
that one came in to us um late 2017 and
we're now
late 2020 three years later we've we've
got to the end of the
the appeal process um obviously
the appeal was due to happen this time
last year so
the covid situation has delayed that um
by 12 months that's you know that's
unfortunate but there are those cases
that will
last that bit longer because of the
complications involved in them
um and the follow-up actions that we we
would necessarily
require um but you know
i think the the oldest case that we've
got on our books probably goes back to
uh 2007 or eight currently
and i think those are ones that we've
gone through all the steps
um with
enforcement and we're now looking at um
uh injunctions to try and get those um
those cases fully resolved we've already
done the enforcement notice steps so
it's on to further legal action
and that comes with some resource
implications so
they become they become more difficult
to to progress because
of the time required to do that and you
know it ends up you end up doing it on a
sort of a piecemeal basis as and when
you can fit it in around the other cases
you
do a little bit more action on preparing
the evidence and exhibits to go with
that
application for an injunction um
your second question council osborne was
around was around case numbers as well
wasn't it
it was yes it was the amount of um
uh amount of enforcement
notices that you've put out and and uh
and how you know how many of those
numbers are not being able to be
enforced due to that
uh well i think if we're if we're
serving in those cases
sorry so again dated cases i i meant to
add first really on that okay so
those cases where we've already served
notice um it would be
extremely unlikely that we would then
decide not to pursue it
um i think before we serve a notice we
make that assessment to ensure that
we've got
a good case um because our expectation
is that it would inevitably go to appeal
and you might end up then
having to take some further action
against it via a prosecution or an
injunction so we want to make sure that
we're
um we pick our battles uh so to speak so
that
only those cases where we um are you
know
you can never be 100 sure that a case is
going to going to
succeed but we need to be you know um
suitably comfortable that it's it's
worthy of the time and
resource that is going to go into it in
order to make sure that we get the
proper result out of the other end
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
appropriate for example necessarily to
serve an enforcement notice on a shed
you know it would be it would be a
sledgehammer to crack a nut essentially
wouldn't it so we would try and
negotiate that one rather than go
go through to a formal notice yeah
can i just can i just add again mr
chairman just just one other thing
i i take it that uh that all the uh how
do you know
the the breach of conditions on policy
are you ex or policy
are you uh expecting the um
residents and counselors ourselves to
actually um
uh come forward to you with with these
or is it
or do you or do you visit sites to see
if they have
been they have been um regularly being
dealt with
i know it's a question that's probably
been asked before but
just to just to to clarify that point
um to answer that one we rely
extremely heavily on members of the
public and yourselves as councillors to
come to us
with um suspected breaches excuse me
we're not resourced to be able to go out
and monitor all the permissions that we
grant
to make sure that they they go ahead in
accordance with the approval
um i think a lot of that is you know on
trust that the developer is going to
proceed in the in the
in the right way and do it as per the
the permission and the approved plans
um so it's reactive as a service
there's not there isn't a proactive
element within
um what we're able to do with the
resource that we've got
that's very helpful thank you simon
thank you mr chairman thank you
i'm going next and then back to
councillor carter if that's okay
councillor muller uh thank you chair no
i have no questions at this stage thank
you
chair thank you councillor carter then
uh sorry thank you um my question was
regarding
uh we heard mentioned that of the tree
pres
preservation via reports about trees uh
yet there's nothing on the chart
regarding it a
couple of organizations for i'm a member
of
during covert have made reports
regarding
uh developments ever chopping down trees
that we weren't sure as were due to
planning
um and to believe there's one about
coppicing
but there's no mention in chart would it
go to a different
chart but it goes to a different
department and
when it comes to enforcement fees uh
would there be like a
tree preservation website a tree warden
that would go
visit to be properties afterwards or
because i've not known anyone to give me
any feedback afterwards
i've not made reports myself but i've
not heard back from them saying that
any for wallop has been taken so how
would that be a
treated nor would it be waiting into
after cover to be
acted on uh
it depends on the tree um if the if the
tree is subject to a tree preservation
order we would put that as a high
priority case and
seek to go out within the the three days
that um john modesty talked about
um earlier um our
uh informal aim is to try and get out
within 24 hours of receipt of
a case like that so that we can um
deal with it as soon as possible if
somebody's up a tree with a chainsaw we
need to be dealing with it
um whilst they're in progress rather
than at some point
at a later date um things like uh
coppicing if it's if it's to do with
hedgerows uh if a hedgerow is coppiced
it hasn't been removed
um the legislation for hedgerows um
states that
for a treat for a hedgerow to be removed
it has to be uprooted
um so if it's if it's coppiced then it
wouldn't be a breach of the regulations
and
um there would be uh no further action
for us to take
the hedgewood essentially the hedge
would grow back um
for much of our uh the trees or hedgerow
cases that we do get we do consult with
our
in-house um agricultural officer to make
sure that we are
approaching it in the correct manner um
and the advice that
that we get from him will will lead how
we respond to the complaint
certainly uh yes thank you i believe the
coppicing one was regarding a willow
tree that had its crown removed and his
farms are where they
do not recover from having his complete
recovery
but um but has answered my questions
appreciated thanks can i move on to
councillor gould and then
councillor caston please thank you um
chair
i haven't got any questions at this time
thank you
councillor casting
thank you very much yes um my question
was um
i maybe it's not something that we want
to go into
in too much depth now but it was with
the review um
um philip isbell said about
that he there was going to be a review
on resources
um i just wondered if we could hear a
little bit more about what that review
is because there's obviously two
different types of resources here
there's resources to deal with
weight of um actions that need to be
done
and then there's resources at the um far
end when you get to your branthams and
um
you know these these really technical
extremely um legally
demanding cases um
up there but i i did withdraw my hand
because i thought this meeting needs to
carry on mr chairman and i don't want to
um
hold up too much but i wonder if we
could have a a little insight into what
that review would
look like
is that one for you to to yes if i'm hm
and i'll just come back on
counselor carter's point about tree
preservation i mean the
the absolute value of going over the
enforcement policy is to look at
uh how we prioritize and deal with uh
cases just such as works to preserve
trees um
you know and at the present point in
time the policy only talks about uh
you know getting somebody out to uh
inspect and uh
start to investigate in in a timely way
and i think there is much more value in
looking at moving those
investigations long one of the ironies
is that some of the older investigations
which have been over 26 weeks old
actually are for high priority cases and
from my point of view high priority does
not stop
stop once you've left sight and and seen
whatever's gone on so i think
there's some there's some interesting uh
review of that activity
necessary to work out uh you know how we
pursue those cases so that they
uh they move to a conclusion i can call
it that
you know in a in in a fairly prompt and
timely way rather than sort of
uh sit around and and don't lead to a an
outcome
and certainly typically preserve trees
uh unauthorized works to listed
buildings are classic items which
require that high priority action
but to turn to councillor castin's
question uh it's not so much a formal
approach as taking stock of where we get
to as i said right at the outset
the process map and all of these things
around enterprise will
do so much but ultimately this is around
how you approach the work and how
uh officers self-manage cases and you
know to that extent
uh there are various things we have one
officer as uh
likely to depart the organisation uh
going to another organization
uh we have one officer on maternity
leave you know the question of what is
the right shape of the enforcement
resource
i.e the right skills and the right
qualifications
and and you know the ability to close
and
deal with the work as we go is something
that is is
not under formal review in that sense
but i think from my point of view once
we've gone further with implementing
the enterprise uh development
and and and making sure that the
timetable uh
is uh credible and works to achieve a
conclusion to an investigation in a
reasonable
time will be better able to work out
whether we've got enough officers
and the right skills officers to
actually uh
carry those cases forward at the moment
i i think all i
could say in response to councillor
casten's question is that this is
something that
simon myself and tom will look at
and we'll keep under review as we
develop and
implement enterprise and as we build up
uh the
the the the sort of expectations around
uh case management
uh because obviously you want to reach a
conclusion in a reasonable period of
time because communities
members need that they need the
certainty that things have been
reasonably investigated
and to do that you need the right skill
a lot of cases
are resolvable within quite a degree of
speed but as we know from viewers and
from other cases
the really chewy ones take a
considerable amount of time and
considerable amount of resource which
can be a distraction and sometimes in
those cases it's appropriate to
uh to call on external advice to provide
some of that
uh assistance which isn't really an
answer to councillor casten's question
other than to say it's not under formal
review in inverted commas
but it remained it's something that i
consider as we go through the spring
we'll get a clarity of of the picture
with
and that will either lead me to
recommend to tom that we need to revise
the shape of the enforcement
uh structure and resource in officer
terms or we'll conclude that it's
it's doing the right thing or or needs
slightly tweaking that's as far as i can
go
thank you uh councillor muller your hand
is now up and then
councillor osborne again yes
thank you chair it's basically really uh
picking up on something that counselor
carter said
and it's just really um i noticed
um the other week that a neighbor in the
next row to me which i i can see through
my
window where i do my office work he had
a tree cut down in his front garden
uh obviously there would be no tpo on
that particular tree but the thing that
concerned me more the company who were
doing it
then seemed to be driving around the
estate toting for business because i
actually called on my next-door neighbor
who has a tree in his garden which is
perfectly safe and
and healthy and fortunate he said no uh
and i wonder if we'd get any more cases
like that
um you know like for unauthorized
approaches to people with trees in their
garden whether we should actually report
the company to enforcement
um because it sort of did ring a few
bells when i saw that uh thank you chair
would somebody have can i come back on
that yes please
if i may i think um as simon indicated
uh
enforcement often gets tasked to look
into a lot of things which are not
actually planning breaches
that that sounds to me perhaps more of a
trading standards matter in some ways
and we have a pretty close working
relationship with other parts of
both the district and the county council
around breaches that affect their areas
and trading standards are no exception
to that we've certainly been working
with them
in relation to caravan site breaches of
control
so i i think the point with that is
uh we're not going to get into
a situation where we're looking to
manage people trying to find business
and you know where we come across people
who have
perhaps done matters which are breaches
of other regulations we'll try and draw
that reasonably to the attention of
other
regulatory areas um and and hand over
the cases there because
it's not probably expedient for us to do
any further work on those and to focus
on the planning
issues thank you phil thank you
councillor osborne your hand is up
uh yeah thank you uh thank you mr
chairman
it was just in in response to um i
believe
uh councillor muller's uh comment about
oh no council carter sorry about
about tree wardens sudbury very
fortunate that we have
uh two tree wardens and when an
application comes to the town council
uh then it's usually the tree warden
that gives a
uh a situation with
with that tree and what the
recommendations
have been given by the by the uh andrew
graham who is the uh
our biologist on on these jobs uh
as to as to what is required whether it
be um
taking the crown out or actually
removing the tree itself
providing it's not a tpo so it's just
trying to be helpful mr chairman
thank you do i have any more questions
no uh counseling well your hand is still
up
okay chair has a legacy hand right
um now um we've we've been looking at
the screen now for an hour and a half i
wonder if
before we go on to debate whether it
would be sensible to have
just five minutes away from the screen
and stretch legs
if that's at all possible can i have
some guidance from officers
whether that would be possible please
yes chair that would be absolutely fine
uh we'll put us a holding screen up on
on the youtube streaming for you
if that's what you require i think that
would be that would be useful
i certainly would appreciate that after
staring at the screen for
an hour and a half um so can we just
take five minutes and
and be back at 11 o'clock is that
possible please
yes thank you
thank you so we have our old call now to
make sure everybody's back with us i
think
yes jim um councillor gould yes
i'm here uh councillor mayberry yes i'm
here thank you
councillor mccror president uh
council mclaren present council osborne
counselor carter
they're present they're still waiting
for my coffee counselor casting
counter casting are you in mute
he's mute he's mute caster caster
i can see you on my screen so i presume
you're here
i'll come back to you in a minute uh
council epcon young
at
are you here
uh
yeah i presume councillor castner's
present since he's unmute
oh sorry yes present thank you very much
that's all presents right so
we've got to the point where we had all
asked our questions but i see
councillor mabry has her hand up is this
to start the debate or is this another
question
no um actually mr chairman it's a
question on reflection one always has to
walk away and then come back and think
of
another one could i just have
confirmation if i may
from one of the offices there was
the comment about 50 000 pounds in
um officer expenses for
the cuckoo hill enforcement i
understood but i may be completely wrong
that the developers were actually paying
the costs
thank you if i can come back on that
yes please do so i don't think i said
that was the office of cost that's
that in essence represents the legal
costs uh at the present point in time
uh and yes we literally have a costs
award against the
uh applicant but if we can't get the
money back out of them then um
that's a pyrrhic victory as it were so
in in literal terms and you there is no
guarantee you'll ever get costs in these
things
um but in literal terms with barrister
time and various other things at the
moment we stand
a little over 50 000 pounds in terms of
um costs to the council and obviously
that's money that's
already been expended so the question of
us recovering it is a different thing
uh i think that uh you know the the
officer element of this
there are obviously the on costs
associated with
uh three witnesses in relation to that
and their time
and attendance and uh typically
you know we will look to recover that um
but it is all resource into into an
expensive activity chairman
thank you thank you very much for the
clarification thank you and councillor
caston
and for debate please chair um okay
that's fine no more questions so
counselor casting i'm happy for you to
kick off the debate
and then i'm going to go round in in an
order so there's no need to put hands up
i will come to everybody
thank you casper casten thank you very
much chair
um so in this summer report
i'm not getting too hung up on these um
on
13 weeks old or less um i think that the
um
the increase in in reporting
is re is a good thing it's a you know
it's good that we're um
we're seeing more people reporting it
shows that
they've got more faith that enforcement
will do
something about their um their claims
and also i think a lot of these will
maybe be solved quite quickly and not
increase the workload
for the enforcement officers the um
the important thing for me is the um 13
weeks sold or more which is um gone down
um since from the first of january it's
gone down i'm
quite a bit to the 23rd of um november
and um i don't expect a lot of these
cases to get solved
some of these cases to get solved in the
26
weeks because some of them are very
complicated and they need to be done
well but i think on a whole
the um the fact that we're doing more
will be a deterrent
which is um which is a really good thing
in enforcement
but um the workflow process mapping i
think is fantastic
i think what what a great
tool to use to deal with these and to
make
make the whole thing more efficient the
um
it seems like um we don't
have an immediate issue with resource
um we um it's something that i'm
really pleased with um phillip
isabelle's answer that this um review is
an ongoing thing and it will be dealt
with if um
and quickly jumped on if um things seem
to get
behind but um i think generally looking
at the um
what's been done here it's it's really
good i think it's um
it's dealing it's dealing with things
efficiently
and um yeah i'm if for noting this
report i think this um
this has come forward and um is working
well
thank you very much council mclaren
thank you chair um i was waiting in turn
for when he came round
sorry um i just i
remember in february when philip
actually presented
his proposals for transformation
i think two things one because i'm
interested in enforcement
but i think probably it was one of the
last meetings we met
in person in endeavor house so it stands
out in my mind and because of that
i remember what he was proposing
i want to commend the officers um
and the team because i think in the
short space of time
and given the difficulties of coving and
everything else i think they've all
embraced the new um
systems i know phillip is saying well
it's not quite there yet
but i think in the time that we've seen
it implemented
i just want to commend them for all the
hard work that they've actually put into
that
i think it today has been um reassuring
with the presentations we've seen thank
you chair
thank you council mclaren councillor
carter
sorry would be lovely if i could get the
words out wouldn't it all right
ah i wanted to echo for you
recommendations to help i think they are
doing an excellent job and under these
circumstances
i did have a quick query or just come to
mind
in regards are these reports available
to
the public about how the workload are um
a a current uh update of what workloads
to officers because if it was available
and we could refer
um public to this then we could actually
uh mitigate some of the complaints about
why we're not
if they're not hearing back so fast blah
blah blah which
we may have from certain residents if
they haven't made a report
if we could say this is a workload
missus of circumstances
i'll pass that to to uh phillip isbell
please
thank you thank you chairman i think
that's an important point counselor
culture i think from my perspective i
would like
as part of the the review of the policy
us to be clear what we're going to be
able to
communicate to members of the community
about our investigations i'd like this
to be a more transparent process i think
one of the things that often frustrates
communities is that
it disappears into a hallmarked
investigation and they don't know what's
going on
now that said enforcement investigations
probably have to be a little more uh
a little less transparent a little more
opaque than planning applications
because
one doesn't wish to uh allow somebody
who's been
been causing mischief to gain the system
so you know there is some whatever
balance here but my own view is that we
can give
members more information the reports
that you have today
contain nothing that we wouldn't tell
anybody if they asked
they don't necessarily show how we're
doing things and obviously if
if we were completely uh candid with
everybody about
uh the the steps in an investigation
then people could probably use the time
that they might see and that to cause a
bit of mischief so we do need to think
about these things
but uh i certainly think there's a point
about greater transparency
and probably my sense is that sharing
that with members
is a sensible way of doing this sharing
this with the public
generally always causes slightly more
problems in terms of how much
information one is prepared to release
that's useful and i think
uh you know we do need to to probably
review that um
within the the task group chairman thank
you very much
you happy with that counselor carter
thank you very much thank you
thank you um councillor osborne and then
i'm coming to councillor mueller after
councillor osborne
councillor osborne
thank you thank you mr chairman um yes
i'd just like to um
uh give my support to the comments made
by
uh councillor casten i think he he's
absolutely right and what he's saying
it is a good thing and the officers that
we have
there today i've done an excellent job
again
along with the um forum that we had and
phil is well was there
um you know it's something that will
i think give a lot of credence to to the
planning side of things and the
understanding of it
which uh in my experience of talking to
residents who have um outstanding
situations with
with enforcement on on applications
do not fully understand but um
as we've all spoken uh around it i think
uh
uh it is a good good example of actually
getting the
uh customers of babel or the
the residents of baber uh particularly
not only baby but mid suffolk to have
more understanding of
of the way the planning and the
enforcement act goes and
as i say again i'd just like to
emphasize my
my extreme thanks to the officers uh
there today
i think john and um
john and um uh
can i remember the lady's name now julie
julie yeah see i've got it here
julie um on there on their um
uh mapped out uh plans uh have been
excellent and
and the comments from simon uh who i've
been been with from from from many
uh uh debates about about enforcement
problems that have arisen in sudbury uh
is an excellent officer to have and and
i think the enforcement side and the
planning side are our excellent teams
thank you
thank you very much uh councillor muller
yes thank you chair yes i would like to
also concur with the comments made by
councillors casting mclaren
and osborne and thank the officers for
the incredible work they're actually
doing
and continuing to do thank you chair
thank you um could i could i just
clarify on
it's an excellent flow chart um could i
just have it
um clarified that um that
that flowchart can still be used if
somebody writes in
on paper i mean it's unusual these days
but it does need to
to be able to cope with a letter coming
in
or something coming in in hard copy but
presumably
it does that doesn't present any
difficulties
or not any unsurmountable difficulties
particularly during covid
i'm assuming that somebody will say yes
it will code
yes it will cope yeah thank you thank
you very much that's great
basically things can come in uh but
reports can come in
using the online form um it could it
could come in via email
or it could come in via post and what
happens if it comes in by
via post is it's scanned endeavor house
and forwarded to the enforcement team so
basically all
all options are covered and eventually
they'll get a piece of paper back with
the outcome
they'll get a piece of paper back
because we have the ability to
to um send letters from endeavour house
so we would email
the post room the post room would send
them out thank you very much that's
that's brilliant thank you
um councillor gould please
yes thank you um can i say as well how
useful i found these sessions
um they were presented and um and thank
you for doing that
um can i just pick up on something you
said phil about
enforcement and what it's appropriate to
tell the communities and
and what it isn't if i understood you
correctly um
i've got an enforcement issue in one of
my parishes that's been rumbling along
for quite a long time
and sometimes
i think non-action
can be read into something which is
actually not
non-action let me try and explain that a
bit more
if there's something which is
confidential and the general public even
parish councils can't have access to
that information because it is a
a sensitive enforcement issue sometimes
our parishes perceive it as non-action
where we are aware that action is being
taken but actually
they can't know the details i don't have
any answers to it i'll just flag it up
as something that i have
picked up um over the months that i've
been a counsellor really
yes right yes i think chairman if we can
give you more information that enables
you to
tell your communities what we're doing
so
if we're getting legal advice for
instance then that makes sense
if we're we won't necessarily share the
advice but you know if we're looking at
serving a notice on somebody then
you know we may uh you know that that's
something that we would probably
actively
be you know we wouldn't necessarily get
into the detail of this and
the actual timing of when we do that may
be something that's a matter of
discretion
with high priority cases they'll be fast
moving and probably
you know all of this will happen you
know quicker than you can record the
actions on on a piece of software
but i think that transparency as long as
it's publicly available
and you know we can make it available to
members certainly
and use that as a conduit for for public
circulation i think then
allows that clarity that people can see
that enforcement
is you know going through a process of
proper investigation with due diligence
and that it's not simply disappeared
into the woodwork
but it has to be balanced and uh you
know there are
for every complaint there will be people
who are disappointed that we are not
taking action
um and and that is something where we we
you know are at risk of by sharing
information that people will try to
achieve their preferred outcome um and
we have to be quite measured in what we
do i think simon also wanted to add
something so
he'll probably correct me if i'm wrong
yes simon
uh thank you chair thanks uh phil uh not
wrong um i just wanted to add that
part of the process map that we've
prepared
includes regular updates um so we're
aware that communication
is something that uh needs to be on our
agenda and that there are those
concerns raised by parish councils and
communities that they're not being
kept up to date on what's going on with
the case that they've brought forward so
we've we've um put into the process
uh tasks which are to to update
reporters and
other relevant elements of those
communities
members for example and parish councils
thank you thank you very much simon um
can i move on to councillor mayberry
please
yes thank you chairman um very much um
this has been again very very useful um
and it's a shame really that
not all members were able to be present
to listen to this um it it is
really insightful it's really useful
it's really helpful
to members um who desperately care about
their parishes
so thank you there was just one item
that i'm not so happy with
um and i applaud the sentiment um from
what um phil isbell has said about
using the joint local plan committee for
the task
um and finish committee
i understand where he's coming from but
this does not give
all members the opportunity to be
involved
and i think that's what i'm saying about
it would been useful
if they had all been at this meeting
this morning
it's it just seems that a few members
will have
all the information that they will have
all
the ability to comment and i just think
that when you're setting up a new task
in finnish group
you need to just
move around the members who actually sit
on it
so thank you thank you
um counselor can we sorry eggplan young
thank you mr chairman um i have um
a few points um with regard
and it's been said and it's it's clear
from the pie charts that the
number of cases that are more than 26
weeks old has dramatically
reduced but by the same token
the number of cases that are from 13
weeks
to 26 weeks and younger have increased
so the overall decline in the number of
cases
from the beginning of the year to now is
very small
but it's it's it's very uh
good to understand that we now have a
very robust process for tackling
uh enforcement which should hopefully
help to uh
dramatically impact the reduction that
um that we would like to see um
so with with that said i think you know
uh
i want to ask philip isbelt perhaps
to explain what is the follow-on process
when it comes to the recovery of costs
that are awarded
to the council against complainants
because clearly
we would have spent a lot of money in in
some instances
and it would be very helpful to to
recover those sums
and it's from what philip was saying it
it seemed that this
might not be something that as
achievable as we might hope
um so i'd like him to address that point
uh
and i would also um echo councilman
mabry's comment i would like to see
a wider member involvement in the talk
and finnish group
so that it it's not so so become
so he doesn't become so much of a sort
of specialized group of people
that are involved in this because uh as
she says
this is something that i think is of
interest to the wider council
group and and and um i think they should
all uh
not all but certainly many of them that
wish to
should try to should participate and get
a wider
knowledge and involvement in this
process thank you thank you
thank you councillor um
chairman if i can come back on young's
questions the first one about cost
recovery um
so if you take the bureau's example as a
case in point
uh it's an enforcement notice which was
appealed
and uh the costs are only recoverable
because that appeal was concluded to be
unreasonable so in essence costs do not
follow the event
unlike litigation um and in that
instance
uh the council was successful but uh if
the appellants grounds had been held to
be reasonable by the inspector
and they'd nevertheless lost costs would
not have been recoverable um service
serving a notice say and securing
compliance
there is no ability to recover costs
against uh
somebody who is uh has caused mischief
or been
been in breach of planning whether
whether deliberately or otherwise
so they fall as simply costs to the
council to absorb
uh the only opportunity for recovering
costs is where an appeal is lodged and
it is in relation to those appeal costs
and not the wider process um as regards
the question of member involved in the
task and finish group
um my recollection and i may be wrong on
this
was that the joint local planning uh the
jlp group was not
a closed membership i thought it was
originally open to
wider members but perhaps there's a
point which should be taken to
individual groups by myself just to
confirm
uh who participates in it i think from
my perspective
that's uh perhaps a useful way of making
sure that the people involved are those
interested in the subject
uh and able to make useful uh
contributions to it which is the most
important point chairman
thank you um simon you you had your hand
up a minute ago
and still is uh thank you chair
i was just going to um respond if i may
on uh councillormon's
point about case numbers um they have uh
come down since
um the since the beginning of the year
um the
uh the pie charts in the appendix
indicate a reduction of um
15 cases in overall workload um but
what we found uh in preparation for for
coming to this committee was that
actually since the first of april
um uh this year we've had 588 cases come
into us and we've had
we've managed to close 487 cases in that
period of time
so whilst the overall number of cases
has dropped but only dropped by a little
um there has been you know a significant
amount of work that's been going on
um behind the scenes and the numbers
don't necessarily overall workload
numbers don't necessarily reflect where
we've got to in terms of um
what we're doing with with workloads so
just to add to the
complexion of that i suppose um just
wanted to mention that particular
stat thank you son did you want to come
back
uh councillor young thank you mr
chairman yes to
simon's point thank you very much for
that simon that's very helpful
um all i would say then is could we uh
when we next have another report
um flesh that out more so it's more
obvious to us
please thank you sure absolutely thank
you
um councillor mayberry
yes thank you mr chairman um i was just
going to come back
to philip israel's comment on the um
on the joint local plan committee i'm
afraid
many members do view it as a closed
shop with the door locked and i
thank him for his comments and i welcome
the input from other members across all
parties into
a new task and finish group thank you
thank you
um council scarf
thank you chair yeah i mean i i can
understand um a couple of the
councillors have mentioned the
composition of the
um the working group but certainly so
far as i'm concerned as a council within
my group
um or joint group we've had quite a lot
of opportunity to have an input into it
uh through our member who serves on on
on the
actual working group so i'm not quite so
uh worried about that and i think there
is
some benefit in having the jlp
members continue with this uh process
um i would like to congratulate um
i think the officers within the planning
enforcement team
because i think uh as the last
answer uh by simon bailey um about the
number of cases that we've currently got
in the number of cases that we've closed
actually puts the
truer picture perhaps on what's actually
happening with the enforcement
um i think it's understandable because
of the covert related issues in terms of
the covid tolerance cases and also
the way that we're able to deal with
cases whilst code
19 is still rife that you know i think
we've made remarkable process so
i progress i think that's really good
but i think perhaps one of the legacy
issues
uh which will seek
will have to deal with and we'll have to
get advice from ohio authority because
the government has allowed these
um expectations that cover tolerance
cases such as
marquees in pub car parks etc uh
are okay whilst they're
economically okay at the moment
of course the distress sometimes that
they can give nearby residents by having
large-scale marquis and pub car park and
more noise
and and light and and so on do also
create a problem so
at some stage um i think the government
has got to give
local authorities some guidance as to
how we can either
regularize those cases and get sort of
like a more permanent temporary
permission for a marquee or something to
exist
and also how we would deal with the
cases where we're allowing
developers to operate outside of what
would normally be considered to be
acceptable hours so i think
that's a real issue i think that we will
have to deal with and i appreciate
there's only 30 cases within that entire
workload
but at some stage we're going to have to
have direction from central government i
feel
on how we are able to continue to
operate that because otherwise
those cases could go on in perpetuity
thank you council council macro
sorry thanks chair microphone wasn't
quite working there
this is a such a an interesting matter
whether we call this enforcement which
is the sort of more authoritarian
approach or compliance which is a little
bit more
persuasive this has been fascinating
stuff
and i i just it's been alluded to that
there's been a series of member
briefings
on the very subject of planning
conditions planning enforcement
permitted development rights and so on
and all of these things relate to each
other so there's a much greater
awareness
of of enforcement and i think that's
rather come out
of this review process that's been going
on we've had our reports earlier this
year
this follows on and now we're
considering where we go
for the next step but there's no
question that the amount of
work that's been done is amazing uh
we've got a clear flow diagram
um our own experiences this has always
been mine anyways that most of our
experience of enforcement issues
is from our own personal experience in
our wards
or perhaps by word of mouth speaking to
other members and
members of the public and of course only
the most noteworthy
enforcement examples will will come to
come to any great attention and of
course as there's been seen there's
quite a large number of cases that cover
a variety
of different areas some are of low
priority some medium and some of
obviously
of high priority we're always going to
remember those of high priority they
will stick in our minds to a greater
extent
but that's a very small sample and we're
looking at the
the overview if you like of the whole
process of planning enforcement so
i think having a structure having that
clearly understood
and perhaps not just by members but also
being able to
demonstrate it to the public as a matter
of transparency
if nothing else because that after all
phil referred to that in his own uh
discussions that there's a point of
transparency not too much
but the right amount is essential so
i'm personally moving towards the idea
that
we should be thinking about the
recommendations at this point um
i would point out though that when we
talk about
a task and finish group um and it's
a task and finish group is is something
that can be set up at any time but it
does make a certain amount of
sense to use an existing task and finish
group particularly if we're relating
our joint local plan to our
joint local plan enforcement so to to
separate the two
could be a mistake but i certainly think
some filtering of new members
into a joint local planning enforcement
policy
a jlp ep and perhaps rotating some of
those members
but retaining the experience that
members will have gained
in developing the joint local plan uh
as a working group so what i'm going to
suggest is this i'd like to propose the
recommendations
as given 3.1 3.2
i would suggest that the conclusion of
the work of the joint member task
and finish group be the right way of
going rather than a six-month
figure so i would remove the words
provided to the committee i would remove
the words in six months
or so that it reads to the committee at
the conclusion
of the work of the joint member and task
and finish group
and that the wording in 3.3
be changed marginally
comprising a basis of the members of the
joint local plan
member working group
with further member input
in other words a movement amongst i mean
because after all not everybody on that
particular working group is necessarily
going to want to stay
others might think they've done their
bit but i think it should be looked at
so i would propose that 3.3
reflect what i think is the will of the
committee councilman mabry referred to
it
other councillors have referred to it we
we want a little bit
more involvement perhaps with different
members but i don't think we should lose
the experience
of those members who've already done
that so those that might that's my
proposal if that can be understood
clearly uh do i have a second or i
suppose
thank you councillor mccraw do do we
have a second uh
happy second that was
council carter oh thank you castle
carter
right um
i think we i i think we should know
and this is uh are we now
in the position um that we should put
this to the vote
um henriette you're
were you wishing to speak uh no
no uh just coming on camera in case you
needed me
one hand still up i don't know if it's a
legacy
counselor maybe no no
it's not it's not a legacy um but i'll
take it down now as i'm speaking thank
you mr chairman
um i i just
feel if we do not put the right wording
into the um proposals or the
recommendations that
i will not be able to vote for this and
it's nothing and it's not
against the officers at all i just
have real difficulty in accepting
if a task and finish group is set up it
is used
it is going to be the majority of the
current joint local plan committee
um and there are quite a few cabinet
members
on it and i just think it is wrong other
members should be
included other members should be able to
have their say
without um the cabinet members
i'm going to say voting together i
re well remember when i was in the
cabinet myself task and finish
groups were usually one cabinet member
and
then members from the if you would like
to call the back benches
and i think that that's how it should be
thank you
councillor mccraw okay i i take the
point um and
if it's about the matter of the wording
as i said comprising a basis of the
members
but you could immediately you could also
alter this just to say
um comprising
how can we put this uh comprising
a a review of the existing membership or
something like that
in other words as again i'm trying to
make this point and i do think it's
important is not to lose that prior
experience
but i also think it's a good idea to
have a review now
the makeup of joint local of any working
group or any task and finish group
is very much a matter of discussion
amongst the various political groups
there are certain officers who
definitely should be included i'd have
to say
it would be a foolish thing not to
include the cabinet member for planning
um or at least of one or both councils
simply because
that's a very relevant position
so i don't want to make it exclusively
non-cabinet or
i think it has to be a balance now how
that balance is achieved
is very much a matter of negotiation
amongst the groups
i don't think this committee can make a
recommendation as to how that
balance should be achieved all we can do
is suggest that it
be achieved and that this these the
points of this committee be
taken into account in in achieving it
i'm not certain about the wording for
this but i think certainly that the
membership
of the jlp ep
should be reviewed so that councilor
mayberries and other members thoughts
can be taken into account thank you um
philip is bill did you want to come in
there
thank you chairman yes i think i i
understand what's being asked bearing in
mind i'm being tasked to go and do
something as a result of this
um and i think what i might suggest just
thinking this through
council mcgraw suggested uh an add-on
after the words joint local plan
member working group with further member
input
perhaps what might then be added to
those words
resolved by the chief planning officer
in consultation with political groups
that would seem to me to give a process
of consultation
um and this is a joint process of
consultation
across both councils uh and perhaps
enable me to get
some clarity about uh who who is uh
you know appropriately invited to attend
in this um
that seems to me one way of doing it
chairman if i can leave i thought
thank you paul councillor macro are you
happy
i think that suggestion that suggestion
is entirely in line with my thinking
uh if councillor carter is still happy
with to second that
excuse me chair before we second
anything can i just have um with further
member input we sold with the chief
planning officer in consultation with
sorry mr ispell what did you say with um
political group leaders political group
leaders thank you very much
councillor carter are you happy to
accept that i certainly am yes
right so henrietta
are are you happy that you've got the
wording sorted
i do have the wording disorder would you
like me to read it to your chair
i think that would be i'd like me to um
because i'm also going to ask
do you want to vote on uh recommendation
3.1
3.2 and 3.3 as a block or would you like
to
vote on them individually i was thinking
on block
chair that's absolutely fine councillor
carter agree but i honestly don't see
any point in trying to separate at this
occasion
that's fine would you like to read the
recommendations out to members then
if you would yes please right so
recommendation you'll be voting on is
3.1
that the contents of this report be
noted 3.2
that a further update on progress b with
service transformation work within
planning enforcement be provided to the
committee
at the conclusion of the work of the
joint member officer
task and phoenix group recommended on
the 3.3
whichever is the later well whichever is
whichever is the later can be of course
removed because
we are not asking for six months so it's
at the conclusion
okay
and recommendation 3.3 that the chief
planning officer
established a joint member officer task
and fitness group compromising a review
of the existing membership
of the joint local plan member working
group with further member input resolved
by the chief planning officer in
consultation with political group leader
leaders to review and make
recommendations
on the joint local planning enforcement
policy and that this group have regard
to best practice and other examples of
published local enforcement policies
in that process of review ideal
thank you right
now i was about to put that to the vote
um counselor ek pinyon have you got
something that
is desperate to be said before we vote i
i do indeed mr chairman i don't think
that the wording that uh
miss holloway has has given us
with regard to 3.3 actually makes sense
although
i note that countless macros seems to be
happy with it
um so i i would like that to be
read out again because um if you look at
the substance of this
um recommendation the membership is
currently comprising members of the
joint local plan
member working group and i think what
we're saying is that it
it would it would in practice uh
comprise some of those members and other
members to be determined by the leaders
of the political
groups according to the uh adjustments
suggested by philip isabel
you're not happy with the word review um
but i mean
no i don't think it's appropriate well
as a basis i think was what you first
suggested councillor mccraw yes i mean
effectively
it's a question it is a little clumsy in
the wording uh
henrietta could you read the um second
line comprising the
okay so what we have on the table is
comprising
every app review of the existing
membership
right comprising after review
would cover that after review comprising
that review process is described later
in the
in the recommendation comprising after
review of the existing membership
members of the joint local plan
member working group with further member
input resolved with the chief planning
officer in consultation with political
group leaders
et cetera et cetera does that cover your
point council rapping young
i'm afraid not countless macro okay
was it would would you uh counselor
equipment would you prefer
something along the lines of comprising
as a basis
the members of the joint local plan
member working group and including
the wording that uh henrietta read out
is that is that what we're looking is it
is it that a review of the members that
you didn't like
correct that's not to me is not logical
as a basis would be logical yes so
it's it's a basis of the group the
existing
group plus others that as suggested by
philip ispel that would be
um recommended by the political groups
as i said you're you're drawing you're
drawing p
the membership is being drawn from an
existing membership
and a wider membership yeah it doesn't
have to
grow though it might be that members
will rotate
different members will come off indeed
we don't want to make it unwieldy so i'm
trying to leave this so that the chief
planning officer can produce
a working group that takes account of
maybe new blood
but keeps the experience of the old
blood i i
i i'm all in favor of that council macro
i i think that the wording really isn't
it absolutely
but that's the essence of it indeed i
completely agree there
so can we find a wording that is
satisfies all those points
i believe we can i'm sure could i
could i make a try 3.3 that the chief
planning officer established
a joint member officer task and finished
group
comprising as a basis the members of the
joint local plant member working group
together with what phil read out
sounds reasonable to me just make sure i
got this
right but i'm terribly sorry
i am spasming amongst so i am
interrupting the
audio is there any chance i could see it
written down in the chat so i can
get basically i'm getting myself
confused with everyone saying
now would it if it be possible to see it
written
certainly one moment let me just let me
just read it out so that everybody
agrees
what it is sorry about that
that the chief planning officer
established a joint member officer
task and finish group comprising as a
basis
of members of the joint local plan
member working group together with
further members member input resolved
with
the chief planning officer in
consultation with political group
leaders to review and make
recommendations on the joint local
planning enforcement policy
and that this group have regard to best
practice and other examples
of published local enforcement policies
in that process of review
council macro are you happy with that
i think the essence of it is there no um
i think a certain amount let's be honest
about this a certain amount of
discretion is going to lie in the hands
of
the chief planning officer and the
political group leaders
that's that's essentially what we're
doing we're not giving carp launch we're
giving guidance
and i think we have to let that guidance
go forward
so right would you like to have it in
the chat
yeah somebody typing that out in the
chat then we'll all have a look at it
and let me just skip that up in the chat
for you
i'm just gonna make sure it's all in one
color
in the chat for you there we are
there you are pizza wheel of death
meeting chat is muted
i can't see that no i've got the meeting
chat is muted
one moment please i'll just check why
that is because i have a feeling
we generally don't use it in live
meetings
so i'm very sorry members we have not
had this issue before
um i do apologize i'm not quite sure
what's happened
mr chairman it's councillor mate
i'm sorry it's councillor maybe here i'm
really sorry but i'm going to have to
leave the meeting
um there is something that's happening
within my home so i apologize but i'm
going to have to go
and if you heard any uh commotion
earlier i apologize
profusely but i will have to leave okay
thank you
mr chairman i just wondered if um
henrietta might
type this out and put it on on a
powerpoint slide and present it
on the screen would be easier maybe i
can just share
my screen let me see what i can do
just one moment you have to bear with my
uh paperwork here but i could share my
screen with you
let me just find it
can members see the screen yes
indeed yes
right does that make sense to members
uh
it does to me so thank you very much for
that
if that if that now makes sense to
members
i think that is that is our new
3.3 from um
from the report can i just ask if
if phil rigg believes that to be a clear
enough
um understanding and basis for uh
a recommendation because phil is the one
who's actually the chief planning
officer who is going to have to carry it
out
i think that gives me enough to work
with and i think i understand the
objectives of committees
yes it does it leaves the flexibility to
allow for change but to retain
experience which is the
which is the purpose of the motion
well i'm happy for that to go ahead if
members are
so uh councillor macquarie as the
proposer is content with that
council carter are you content
to remain as the seconder of that i am
quite content and i appreciate for your
length sconce to accommodate me so thank
you vet
right so chair are we still voting on
block then
we will we will vote for we will vote on
block and they will appear
they'll appear won't they it will appear
the recommendation in the vote in
modern.gov voting will see
will say that the recommendations 3.1
3.2 and 3.3
are spread out by the governor's officer
be approved
and we can start the book for you now
this pesky bar won't come down
[Music]
okay henriette um my vote is four
you're full that's that's thank you very
much
mr chairman uh it's castle scarf here um
i'm looking at the voting section on um
modern.gov and
i can't see a blue line so i don't know
whether other members can or not
the bar is difficult you may need to
scroll
down a little bit okay yeah and the
thick bar doesn't show until you
actually hover over it
thanks i've got that now it it was it
was the scrolling down bit
that didn't appear very easily i think
that's one of the technical difficulties
with this system
i think it's to be homeless i think it's
to be hoped that modern gov will uh
actually eventually show that bar rather
more clearly
yeah lovely thank you i'll do that now
then thank you
thank you very much members do we do we
have everyone having voted now
we are still waiting for three members
to
just a vote more seconds i think
so henrietta um gold can't vote
and councillor so you've received all of
your votes now
right thank you very much we have eight
eight
votes for jam thank you
thank you very much indeed right we now
move
on to the next item on the agenda
which is deferred it's to be deferred to
the
uh mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny
meeting
in uh january
can i just can i just interrupt chairman
yes i've not had an opportunity to vote
i couldn't make it work
and i was trying to get back into the
meeting all right
so my vote has not been sorry registered
um let me just check
just bear with me i can check and see
who's voted just bear with me
maybe i can get mandy to help me as well
just one moment
i'm just checking myself sorry yes i'm
just trying to
uh um
so yeah sorry councillor mclaren we
haven't received your vote either
and i couldn't i couldn't make it work
so but my vote is
for republicans
chair so that is nine votes for thank
you very much
and none against and now stan against i
know
you're right thank you thank you very
much right um
so that concludes item seven on the
agenda
um can i oh
i think have the um are the officers
still there can i if they are still
there can i thank them very much indeed
uh it's been quite a long morning for
you but we're really
really grateful for all of the
information that you have given us
and i think we have come to a sensible
conclusion there
um and we look forward to hearing back
again uh
at the conclusion of the work of the of
the task
group thank you very much thank you
chair
thank you um so we move on to
item eight which is deferred
until the uh deferred to the mid-suffolk
scrutiny meeting in january uh item nine
is the forthcoming decisions list
which is to be noted is that does
anybody want to say anything about the
forthcoming
decisions list
no um so we move on to
items 10 and 11 the two work plans
is there anything to be said on the
baber
overview and scrutiny work plan
i don't believe so thank you
and um in terms of the mid-suffolk
overview of scrutiny work plan
we just need to add the item
about the additional recommendation on
the review of the outside bodies
the mid-suffo disabilities forum
and so those those two are both for
noting
and that concludes the meeting thank you
very much indeed
thank you to the officers thank you
members um
for a really good debate thank you very
much
you